i think if you look very very way back
in history food has been a big
determinant force in from the
definitions and there are spice trades
to the Orient and bringing back and we
can actually less certain e sigma one of
the richest sort of city state which in
turn with its mint money created
florence and the sub trades which in
turn fueled the renaissance order so
food is potent you know the the travel
of columbus was to find the new to find
yes the Fountain of Youth but also was
to find new foods and new ideas so food
is extremely in important in the
evolution of what happens in the world
happen and it continues to happen I
think certainly climactic forces the
mobility of everything and my least
favorite is of course industry in the
sense that you know they take in food
and again done with it some
inventiveness and packaged in your
market and something that's absolutely
might not be necessary it now is deemed
a must-have and I have problems with
that
you